are we gonna address
the uh outfit you're wearing we could
dress it sure
you know for those who are colorblind
my michael's wearing the or just
listening to this
[Laughter]
michael's wearing the exact opposite the
inverse
from uh from another dimension outfit
which is a white suit and black shirt
uh so genius okay so uh you just see the
next two looks i've planned
oh no yeah they're great well obviously
this relationship is going to end today
i'll put that on instead okay
is there some deep philosophy to the
humor
is uh this goes to our trolling
discussion
is there some is there like chapters
to this genius or is this just uh what
makes you smile in the morning well
i mean i think you're honestly in this
case using the word genius a little
loosely
this is particularly genius but i do
think it is fun
it is exuberant it is joyous um
i think the the bigger my audience has
gotten
and the more i actually communicate with
you know fans i do feel it kind of kicks
in these paternal maternal instincts
it's which is very very odd i did not
expect to have that what do you mean
who's the dad i'm the dad and the mom i
remember
and it may have been similar for you i'm
curious to hear it for young
smart like um ambitious men like 24 to
for me was a very rough period because
that's the window where a lot of people
get married and they kind of check out
and if you're very much kind of finding
your own road
you don't know what's happening no one's
in a position to really guide you or
help you
and it's it's it's tough it's a very
tough window
and what i'm finding now is having these
kids
who are in that position but now
instead of them stumbling along for some
of them i'm the one who could be like no
no
no it's not you it's everybody else and
to be able to
give them that semblance of feeling
seen to use a cliched expression to feel
normal and that no no you're the you're
the you're the heroes here
they're the background noise um it's
just really
very uh flattering and humbling to be in
that position
you have many minds right there's the
thoughtful kind
michael there's like i'm gonna burn down
the powerful
yeah mike yeah and then there's like i'm
going to have
this just light-hearted trolling of the
world
yeah which and which of those are
most important to the 24 to the 27
demographic
i i think it's it is the combination you
know it's like if you're making
a meal you know chicken kiev you need
the chicken you need the
ham you need the butter sauce um
because i think people when you're young
you need to see someone who's fought the
fight for you
and who's won so it's very easy to be
defeatist
so this is what winning looks like no
this is not
this is most assuredly what winning does
not look like but in my normal clothes
yeah a little bit more uh this is a good
time to mention that
clothes wise you're wearing sheath
underwear
and people should buy sheath underwear
use code malice20
if you go to sheetsunderwear.com use
promo called malice20
what i love about the why i'm glad to
promote the product and wear it
it's the most comfortable underwear i've
ever worn and you have a separate pouch
for both parts of your genitals
that's that's what you i thought there
was like a punch line coming
no it's a very nice aspect of the
product yeah
you